[Music]
the fan I mean the phenomenon of
dreaming became very important in
specific parts of branches of Buddhist
philosophy where in general the whole
idea that the the world is in some way
illusionary it was became a major
intellectual focus and different
different Indian thinkers in particular
try two different ways of trying to
explain that and trying to make sense of
what that means and one way of trying to
explain it was was saying look the
entire world is mental in substance
right so when we look at things so I see
this tent over there and there's
actually not and there's not an external
object out there but it's rather what I
see is some some construction or
concatenation of mental things of ideas
or different moments of consciousness or
something like that right so what
they've been trying to do there was
trying to develop a theory of the
external world that didn't assume that
the fundamental entities or the
fundamental constituents of reality are
bits of matter but bits of mind right so
that extent it's it's quite an
interesting way of trying to come up
with a theory that is the complete
inverse of we normally what we normally
think is the best way of explaining the
world namely first of all explaining the
material a bit and then see how mind
gives rise to that well they were trying
to do was the other way around they
started with the idea of consciousness
in mind is a primitive and then they try
to come up with an idea of how the
material word could arise from that and
where are your own thoughts on this do
you think mine comes before matter or
matter comes before mind ah well that's
a good question I think well if you if
you answer the question either way
you'll have to assume that there is some
level of reality that is fundamental and
everything comes from that right so we
have a kind of foundationalist picture
now I think that is probably is probably
not a satisfactory way of thinking it in
the end because what you end up with is
a set of entities such that the
the penetration goes both ways right so
the material stuff determines mental
stuff and it make the staff determines
material stuff so it goes it goes both
ways round in which case you'll end up
with a position where you have no
fundamental theory or you have no rock
bottom ontology to explain it all so you
end up with this kind of coherent is
picture where everything depends on some
other things but there are no completely
independent things yeah so I think that
is the most the the most satisfactory
philosophical way of thinking about it
and so do you think that means that we
shouldn't trust our senses or perception
or we put too much trust in them
currently well it depends on what you
want them to do right
so I'd obviously put a lot of trust in
my senses if I want to get from here to
the other end of the field because my
senses allow me to navigate the tents
are not to trip over things and so on so
in to that extent they are they are
quite reliable but the question is
whether you would want to say that
therefore you can use them in order to
settle all question in particular
whether that you can use them in order
to find out what the one true account of
reality really is right and even whether
you should assume it there is such a
thing yeah so I think that is a there is
a difference in suffice you might want
to trust conventional reality at the
conventional level but not in the
ultimate level for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you